these are tough times for sale the tent
where she lives was overcrowded so she
sent two of her children along with
grandchildren to Ankara
she misses their old life together
ruptured by the quakes
we desperately need help it was planning
planning my daughter's wedding when the
Quake hit but we lost her house and all
the valuable gifts we bought for her
tell me what I can do I have seven
children and need help so I can look
after their needs
hear the same story and the same
concerns across a vast region devastated
by two powerful earthquakes
this is a delicate moment for the
government which has been facing anger
in the 11 provinces hit by the
earthquakes but officials say that the
earthquake mobilization and the
financial aid are the largest in modern
Turkish history but many here are still
worried that after losing everything
their loved ones their homes and their
livelihood they may not get all the
support they need
people are queuing for food and then
waiting for their turn in front of
mobile cash machines to receive money
right after experts inspected the damage
to my house I received an SMS message
saying 530 dollars in compensation
every family will receive 250 dollars as
a rental payment Aid and a hundred fifty
dollar monthly allowance for one year
a mammoth commitment for a country
dealing with a string of economic
problems but in the meantime its ngos
and volunteers who are stepping into The
Fray
[Music]
these are students from Shanley orfa on
their way to entertain children in the
makeshift camps in adiama
[Music]
if we can make them smile that would be
great if they are happy they will spread
happiness they are our future and our
hope
for a few moments it's time for fun
volunteers turned clowns providing a
reminder of happier times and they hope
a glimpse of what's to come
and Hashem joins us now live from Karma
marash one of the affected areas in
Turkey so Hashim president erdogan is
under pressure as we've heard to do more
he's promised to rebuild in a year is
that realistic
it's going to be a mammoth task for
president
erdogan wherever we go in the in these
areas David devastated by the two
powerful earthquakes we see excavators
trucks Vehicles deployed because this is
a Race Against Time the government wants
to clear the mountains and mountains of
rubble to start laying the foundations
and delivering homes in a year from now
why in a year from now because as my
colleague silam was saying in
in Ankara there is a political aspect of
this story particularly with the
upcoming elections that the government
wants to give a sense to the people that
they are
dealing with the situation that they are
going to deliver when it comes to the
plate pledge is bad the opposition says
that the time frame is over ambitious
politically motivated and wrong and that
the government should wait for some time
and rethink the whole seismic design
code across turkey which is an
earthquake-prone country now when you
look at the economy itself it has been
suffering over the last few years where
the Turkish lira losing 34 of its value
with growth shrinking from 11 to
something like uh three percent the
World Bank estimates because of the
damages to be at around something like
34 billion years dollars and many
experts are saying that you need at
least something between 50
to a hundred billion dollars to rebuild
the areas that were devastated and to
put together all the recovery plan it's
going to take many many many many years
and it's going to be a closer uh project
and plan for the government of President
is he going to deliver we have to wait
and see but this is definitely going to
be a pivotal moment both for him for his
legacy for the legacy of the ruling
party and also for the Turkish
opposition which is looking forward to
reinvent itself seize the opportunity
move forward they know that this is the
moment for them if they want to move
forward when it comes to winning hearts
and bind to the people ahead of the
elections thank you ashim for that very
interesting Hashem